n'aura pas une miette des recettes
exécutés par les chefs lui aussi va
bientôt présenter sa recette à ses
idoles inchy parmentier de patates
douces
en fait c'était ma tête allait de ses
cuisines elle cuisine et elle dans le
bourg de saint pierre et plus je crois
que ça m'a inspiré
moi j'adore cuisinier ne s'est pas cessé
depuis tout petit l'amour de la cuisine
créole c'est ce qui rassemble
aujourd'hui les participants de ce grand
show culinaire
douze chefs autant de plats proposés
autour de produits locaux tous agrémenté
d'une touche de rome bananes flambées
caramélisées au
aux fruits de la passion vanille de
voile ou bio et fin bon vieux saint
james
ensuite on va incorporer un espuma sino
mousse de caramel beurre salé et vanille
bio de boileau et un petit chris pine
citron vert et chocolat blanc c'est très
frais en bouche et puis on sent bien la
banane qui a été légèrement pour aider
l'alliance avec notamment la vanille
c'est très très belle issue et face à
ces chefs reconnus comme orlando c'est
celle de sainte lucie les fins gourmets
affluent pour assister au spectacle
tu es là c'est très simple c'est du thon
c'est savoureux et c'est facile à
cuisiner
j'ai voulu expérimenter l'association
tôt
c'était sympa des chefs étoilés et lé
meilleur chef de la caraïbes réunis pour
mettre en valeur la gastronomie et le
rhum martiniquais à travers le créole
fudan roms l'union des métiers et des
industries de l'hôtellerie souhaite
dynamiser le secteur de la restauration
[Applaudissements]